all right
years ago probably i don't know 2014
um i probably spent 1500
on buying bitcoin um and i probably made
a hundred and twenty thousand dollars
off of it um so i it was
it was such a small amount i just i like
i bought it and i just
left it i never did anything with it um
i know it's very risky and everything
but i didn't really put anybody into it
um what do you guys what do you guys
think about that is
are you saying you can cash it out today
for a hundred grand
for sure okay so by not
okay there's a process in finance called
sunk cost analysis
all right and so if you don't cash it
out today
in the morning you have reinvested a
hundred thousand dollars into bitcoin
that should scare your brains out
it's not fifteen hundred it's a hundred
thousand
every day you leave it there you are
reinvesting
into this again right
by nightfall dude cash it
okay bitcoin is going over 50 of your
freaking net worth
is on the roulette table
on one roll of the dice it's in code
yeah if you if you really can cash it
out and
you may find out that this is funny
money but i hope you can
i hope you can too and run stream run
away
run away yeah you know um
i you know this is one of those things
you guys where
again you're hearing about this stuff
out there and it sounds too good to be
true
it is and you got to be careful you
really do
i've talked to a lot of people that have
been burned on this and unfortunately
have gone the route of even leveraged
investing schemes
which is pulling money out of their
house to invest which is absolutely no
no
and so just be smart do long-term
investing
whenever you try to get rich quick what
i found is you end up getting broke
fast and so you want to have a mindset
of building wealth over time
you know the i i hope that you can cash
it out when you go to do it tonight
i'm suspect when i hear 1500 turns into
100 000 i'm really suspect that you that
you're getting
um i i hope you can
i hope you can i'll just leave it at
that i hope you don't find other things
when you go try to cash it out
um but those numbers are are bizarre
and um and if it if you are able to cash
it out the
other danger is isn't that you actually
pulled off this crap once and it's going
to tempt you to do it again
so um but you do whatever you want to do
but i i am not a fan of ultra high risk
investments
and uh at a minimum that's what we would
call bitcoin
at a minimum we could call it a lot of
other stuff too whole lot of things
but um yeah and also an alternative
currency well even if it is an
alternative currency i don't buy
currencies well and the other side is if
you can't do that the other phone call
you need to make is to a tax elp
uh so you can understand the realized
gain on that
because you are going to deal with uncle
sam on the growth and
again you know i think daniel you
walking through the process and being
very intentional
with this and on the other side too with
this wildlife thing that you're wanting
to pursue
i want you to have a burning passion for
it not just be interested in it
because you're about to take a whole
nother shift in life uh
and i hope you're not doing that just to
get away from the hotel industry uh
there are a lot of things that you can
do without making this kind of lifestyle
change
yeah yeah that's um that's true